The winter holidays were here at last!
It was Nami's job to make a special gift for everyone.
It was her family's tradition.
Grandma Kato loves plants.
Nami made her grandma a flowerpot.
Then, she put it in a red box.
Grandpa Kato loves sugar cookies.
Nami made her grandpa cookies.
Then, she put them in a red box.
Cousin Mika loves elephants.
So Nami wrote her cousin an elephant story.
Then, she put it in a red box.
Uncle Yuri collects coins.
So Nami made her uncle a large clay coin.
Then, she put it in a red box.
Nami didn't know what to make for Aunt Hoshi!
She didn't know what was special to her aunt.
Nami looked for clues.
First, Nami saw that Aunt Hoshi had a baseball key ring.
Then, Nami saw Aunt Hoshi's socks.
They had tiny baseballs on them.
Next, Nami saw Aunt Hoshi watching baseball on TV.
Nami knew just what to do.
At last, it was time for Nami to give her gifts.
Each person smiled when they opened the gift made just for them.
Aunt Hoshi jumped up when she took hers out of the box.
"Let's play ball!"
she called.
Then she went to the basement holding her baseball and bat.
The family played baseball late into the holiday night.